-Our first guest tonight is
an iconic, Emmy-winning actor.
His memoir, "Being Henry:
The Fonz and Beyond,"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend,
Henry Winkler, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, Henry.
-I'm so glad Connor is here,
because he's the most requested.
I'm going out on the road,
so I just want you
to keep a slot open for me.
-You maybe need a touring
drummer with you?
-That's all I have,
is a drummer.
-Oh, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-Just you, Henry on stage
with a drummer.
-A joke and a ba-bum.
-Oh, you need that.
-Yeah.
-There you go.
That's very smart.
Henry, I'm so happy you're here.
Your energy
is one of my favorite
in all of showbiz.
-You don't have to say that.
-Well, it's a true thing.
I know we can't talk
about your acting,
and thank God,
because of the SAG strike.
Thank God.
I don't want you to think
I don't want to talk about it,
because it's not exceptional.
-No, no.
The strike, it should be over.
-It should.
Well, I hope it ends soon.
-How does a town
that makes entertainment
for the entire world
not come together and go,
"You know what?
We can figure this out."
-I know. They make dreams.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Make some dreams come true.
So se can't talk about
your acting.
And thankfully --
-This is a new sweater.
-Is it a new sweater?
-It's a new sweater.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers ]
-Now, be honest,
when you buy the sweater,
do you think, "I'm going to
save it for Seth"?
-Yes.
-Really?
-You know what?
I know you're a bad liar,
so I'm going to take you
at your word.
-Okay.
-Alright, so we can't
talk about your acting,
but you did --
-That character.
-We can talk about
this character right here.
This gentleman,
I think we know very well.
-You know what I can do?
-What?
-Heyyy.
-There you go.
You can do that,
and we know
who you're talking about.
And then I added a word.
"Whoa."
-Yeah.
-Did you, was that your idea,
was "whoa"?
-It was mine.
It came from my favorite sport,
horseback riding.
-Oh, really?
-"Hey, Paula, whoa."
-Because you were an
equestrian in your youth.
-I was. Now...
-Right.
-...it's impossible.
-Sure, you're too busy.
-I can't even walk down stairs,
let alone straddle a saddle.
-I feel like a lot of
actors and actresses
don't like to talk about
their past work.
They want to say,
"Oh, I've moved on."
-This guy --
-You love this guy.
-Do you know
how loyal this guy is?
He gave me notes on this guy.
-Really?
-He had me cut page 57.
-I mean, over the years,
I assume some years
more than others,
this was probably a very popular
Halloween costume.
-You know what? It was.
I have the original costume
still in the packaging.
-Really?
-Yes.
I thought that would be sort of
at a museum of some kind.
-The jacket.
-Okay, the jacket.
The jacket's in the museum.
You've got the rest of it.
-The jacket is in the museum.
-Okay, that's very good.
Did you ever have a trick
or treater come to your door?
-Do you know what?
My grandson, Ace,
my grandson,
my oldest grandson...
My favorite thing
is to go to my daughter's house,
sit on the stoop with
with my grandsons
and all of their friends
and the children that come
and my granddaughters come
and give out the candy.
And I walked into the house,
and he was dressed with his hair
slicked back as the Fonz.
[ Crowd awws ]
-Yeah?
-My heart flew out of my body,
honest to God.
-That's really wonderful.
-Yeah.
-You seem to have
a great many positive memories,
not just about your work
and also about your family.
When you write a memoir
like this,
I imagine you also
have to do research.
Were there things that you,
through writing this book,
remembered that you'd forgotten?
-Do you know what?
I made a long list of things
I forgot that I didn't remember,
you know?
And I kept saying,
"Can I put them in the book?
Can I put them in?"
And they said, "Well, you know,
the soft cover is going
to come eventually."
[ Laughter ]
-Gotcha.
-That's a very polite way
for an editor to say no.
-"No."
-Yeah.
-Also your lovely wife, Stacey,
was here tonight,
who is often here with you.
-Yes.
-And I'm very happy to see her.
You gave her a platform
to add in to this book.
Well, I didn't give her
the platform.
Her platform is hers.
-Okay. Got it.
-Yeah, I think
she even built it.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Some might even say
it's a pedestal.
Hello? Hello?
-So was this an effort
to get her side
of certain memories or...?
-You know, with all
the children's books
that I've written,
I wrote with a partner, Lynn,
and so I was comfortable
with that.
And then my son, our son Max,
who is a director
and a producer now,
and he always said,
"You got a lot of stories, Dad.
You should write a book.
You should do your memoir."
And I said, "I can't do that."
So Esther Newberg --
-Why did you think
you couldn't do it?
-Because a lot of the time,
I think I cannot do something,
and then I bore myself
with the "no,"
and eventually just say,
"Shut up and just try it."
-Sure.
-And it turns out that,
here's a book.
-That's great.
-I met a man
by the name of James Kaplan,
and I didn't know
that it was my responsibility
to fly James Kaplan
out to California twice,
put him up,
and feed him three times a day.
-So you're saying this man
is a con man?
-I'm saying this man
is a good eater.
-Okay, gotcha. That's
a very polite way of saying it.
-But he is also
a wonderful collaborator
and a wonderful writer.
-That's great.
-And so because of him,
I was able then to make it
come together.
-Was the process,
you would sit with him
and you would tell these stories
that you've told over the years,
and then he would help
shape it into...?
-Exactly right.
And then I would deconstruct it,
I would add, like,
I thought there was a joke
at the end of a story
that was left out
or that I wanted to put in,
maybe a person that was left out
that I wanted to include.
-I would imagine
you're the sort of person
who makes sure that important
people to you and your career,
you would want them
to be included.
-You know what,
that is exactly right.
I had that feeling.
And the reason is
because without them,
I would not be here.
You don't get here
into this chair
with the great Seth Meyers
by yourself.
You get here because
people have supported you,
people have helped you,
people have written for you
or whatever it is.
-That's really lovely.
-It's true.
-I'm gonna write a book called
"I Did It by Myself."
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
[ Applause ]
-You know that's not true.
-I know it's not true,
but it is a really good joke.
-A really good joke.
-It's a really good joke.
-I have a lot more questions
for you,
because this is
not your first book.
You guys, we'll be right back
with more from Henry Winkler.